Based on my genetic testing, May 2023, pro-hydroxychabolomy,
we'll also today, in phase two, two per day, we're recommended.
These are not, they do a supplement list.
Are these no longer necessary for me?
So when I test people, I'm testing them
what is on their cancer and things, not on what is genetic.
So the genetic thing isn't based upon,
we make a recommendation based upon your genetics,
that's not based upon parisiology testing,
it's based upon what was on your genetics.
So this is a really good question
when it needs clarification.
I don't always add that to your thing.
So what you were recommended to do
from a genetic standpoint, you should always stay on that.
Really, and definitely, your genetics don't change.
The genes don't get better.
They only get worse.
So yes, they can get worse.
So if you read a new genetics that you,
maybe you read a new genetics 10 years ago
and you read a new one, it could be different
because you could have more defects.
Why?
Because what causes defects?
Well, you would hear it defects from your parents,
but you also acquire defects from your environment.
So if you're exposed to a toxin,
a.k.a. like chemotherapy,
and you run your genetics post chemotherapy,
it could be worse because toxins affect your genes
and you could have damaged genes
and you could have worse genetics.
That would not be any close to being out of the question.
So when recommendations are based on your genetics,
their based on your genetics, those don't change.